you've been with Liev Schreiber for 10  years now yeah right when he's an  amazing actor incredible guy you live in  New York City and the whole family gets  around by bicycle apparently sometimes  but then we got this this watch is shot  if you you do not look happy about it  and you're delivering newspapers I guess  you guys should spring for another bike  - well my bike got stolen  oh really and then I just thought you  know because we're coming out to LA so  much I wasn't gonna buy another one so I  did the city bikes for a couple years  right the rental yeah yeah they're good  those are good yeah I see those those  okay you can't steal those right I've  tried you just can't steal yeah yeah  I've got more of them in my closet  you